[Musique]
erika velho et une ingénieure
réunionnais installé aux pays-bas
originaire de la plaine saint paul elle
est la mémoire grise qui permet que les
fusées puisse être mise en orbite je
travaille dans ce milieu depuis une
quinzaine d'années et j'ai travaillé sur
différents types de
on va dire métier parce que je suis
passé sur le suivi de production des
tâches de fusées au développement du
logiciel aussi d'une fusée de la fusée
ariane 5 est aujourd'hui aux pays bas
âge on occupe vraiment des équipements
de satellites tels que des panneaux
solaires pour les modules de services de
capsules typiquement là depuis deux ans
travaille sur ce projet perd programme
de la nasa s'appelle artemis qui va
permettre de construire une capsule pour
envoyer de nouveau des gens sur la lune
dont la première femme
qui marcherait sur la lune
ce sera vraiment très symbolique erika
belliot a tenu à rencontrer les élus du
conseil départemental des jeunes à la
villa du département en 1996 elle était
elle-même à leur place moi j'avais
travaillé sur une commission pour la
réinsertion des prisonniers de la prison
du port ont les aider lorsqu'ils sortent
de pouvoir serez intégré à une vie
active et une vie de citoyen donc on
avait carrément
l'initié et créer une bibliothèque pour
ces prisonniers de façon vraiment à leur
apporter l'éducation nécessaire pour
pouvoir se sentir à l'aise à leur sortie
est typiquement j'avais été j'ai
toujours été très engagés et impliqués
dans ce péché et ça me rappelle de très
bons souvenirs d'être ici j'ai hâte de
rencontrer ces jeunes la place de la
femme dans la société est un sujet qui
lui tient à coeur et qui n'a pas manqué
d'interpeller les jeunes juste ces défis
c'est une femme tellement inspirante que
je me dis peut être un jour j'arriverai
au même stade quelle la même fierté là
le même charisme à lire et donc la
inspiration pour les jeunes de nos jours
peut-être que ce sera moi à sa place
c'est moi qui en ai fait une conférence
c'est moi qui me présentera et donnerait
aux jeunes aux jeunes filles oh oh oh
personne du cdj que ce soit madame jesse
et c'est la joie et la bonne humeur la
la comment dire c'est la convivialité
qui nous a donné aujourd'hui la matinée
s'est achevée avec la rencontre entre
eric avait lieu le président du
département cyrille melchior
[Musique]